wenn wir jetzt trotzdem einmal
Eintauchen in ihre Geschichte ich will
es nur einmal vorher wissen wie
schmerzhaft ist das für Sie wenn Sie all
das wieder und wieder erzählen was
damals passiert ist ich nenne mich
Humanist
intellektuell und ich habe nicht
zugelassen dass Hitler siegen sollte und
das soll mein ganzes Leben zerstören ich
kenne Leute die ganze Palette von Leuten
wie sie gerade äh haben nie darüber
sprechen wollen oder können genau bis zu
Leuten die von nichts anderem sprechen
können als ihrem Leiden das ist
schmerzhaft zufahren bei mir ich bin
Rationalist ich nehme Sachen ich habe
die Sache nicht überwunden aber
bearbeitet meinem Gehirn und nehme
Sachlichkeit vor allemm und vor allem
ist sehr ein voll überzeugt mhm dass es
nützlich ist darüber zu sprechen die
Wahrheit über den Alltag unter den Nazis
zu berichten und das wahre Gesicht und
vor allem dass wie hier schon erwähnt
wurde es fängt an mit aigung gegen
andere von oben herabschauen auf andere
missachten andere und das führt geraden
weeges in den gaskamme wenn wir einmal
zurückgehen in die Zeit wir haben das
eben schon
kurz gesehen sie wachsen auf
geboren in Lodge
äh ihr Vater verstirbt sehr früh
schwierige Verhältnisse ihre Mutter muss
sie und ihre vier Schwestern irgendwie
durchbringen dann kommt dieser Überfall
und sie werden gezwungen ins Ghetto in
in Lodge zu gehen ich war selbst mal
dort also man kann das nicht mehr
wirklich sehen aber ich kenne die
Berichte ich weiß ein bisschen wie
abgeschirmt das war ich weiß auch wie
eng das war wie diese Züge da
durchgefahren sind wie irgendwann tote
Menschen Leichen links und rechts lagen
und andere auf dem Weg zur Arbeit in
diesem Zug sitzend aus dem Fenster
gucken die beißen in ihr
Frühstücksbrötchen und sehen diese toten
Menschen links und rechts fahren durch
dieses Ghetto durch steigen am Ende
wieder aus und sind bei der Arbeit wie
haben sie das erlebt als jemand der im
Ghetto drin war diese beengten
Verhältnisse diese Verzweiflung die
Krankheiten die sich breit gemacht haben
der Hunger wie haben sie das
erlebt ich würde mit dem Wort Hunger
anfangen es kann sein dass sie am Tage
so intensiv beschäftigt sind dass sie
gezwungen sind LCH Mittagszeit zu
überspringen und Glauben gegen Abend
dass sie fürchterlich hungrig sind das
ist kein Hunger in meinem Begriff ist
das gesteigert Appetit aber vom
September
1939 mm bis Z Befreiung um den 20 April
1945 mit deer einzigen ich wiederhole
einer einzigen
Ausnahme an Hunger buchstäblich gelitten
nicht ein einschlafen können abends
durch den schwerzhaften Druck in der
Magengegend morgens aufwachend dem
Hungergefühl und was
das wichtigste ist V an nichts anderes
denken können als wie kann ich etwas zu
essen zu bekommen ich bewundere die
einsassen in Ghetto lismanonstadt denn
in LGE gab es kein Ghetto das GTO wurde
errichtet durch die Nazis
1940 im Namen eines deutschen Generals
nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg li man auch be
viel Hitlers
übrigens dass sie die noch im Stande
waren zu denken Tagebücher zu
schreiben das war für mich unfassbar ich
konnte an nichts anderes denken sie
haben gesagt sie sind ein einziges Mal
in diesen se Jahren satt geworden wann
war das als ich wie später erwähnen wird
auf auschnits entkommen bin nach
großosen war ich in Außenlage wnau ich
habe Projekt Riese für
Stromversorgung
gearbeitet ich war masteiger ich habe
die Leitungen angebracht und der
arbeitsleiter von der Organisation
to andere Uniform ich kann mich erinnern
mit ihm irgendwann ein Wort gewechselt
zu haben aber eines Tages kam er morgens
an hat ein Schreiben vorgezeigte Wache
das unterschrieben hat übernimmt die
Verantwortung für mich er muss mich als
den Fachmann mit dem Material zu
versorgenm als war ein Vorwand wir
landet in ein der Stadt wahrscheinlich
Waldenburg mm denn dieses dnau war
zwischen brestau und Waldenburg wir
landeten ein eine Wohnung eine junge
Frau öffnete
uns mich haben sie in die Küche gesetzt
vor eine terine mit Suppe und so ein
Stoß Brot die verschwand
wahrscheinlich im
Schlafzimmer ich habe gegessen und
gegessen und gegessen und gegessen Hände
Ringen zum Himmel sie sollen sich so
lange wie möglich
amüsieren dass ich so lange wie möglich
andere luftatmen kann als die Lagerluft
denn die Lagerluft war furchtbar wir
waren in auf
britzen zu Zeh
am hat ich mein Stückchen Brot z im Kopf
gelegt aber dann verschwand es unter der
Nacht habe ich unter dem Arm gelegt dass
ich es sich haben kann es waren schlimme
ich hatte noch der Vorteil dem ich auch
zum Teil das Lieben
verdanke war das in diesem Beruf war ich
erstens oben auf dem Stolpen
weitentfern von den Kolben der SS Männer
vor allem junge Kerle hab sich
gelangweilt saßen es war ja Winter
geworden mhm wir wurden gefangen im
August und dann im Oktober nach
großrosen und
dnau November geworden Winter wir hatten
keine Kleidung nur dne Jacke und Hemd
ich konnte mir erlauben meine Decke
fdecke in ein Dreieck zu legen um die
Brust zu spannen und hinten am Rücken de
Stück drah zu verbinden weil ich nicht
kontrolliert wurde ich wurde aus der
Baracke geholt
der arbeitsleit kam mit
einem
Motor mit
Beiwagen Motorrad mit Beiwagen war
Beiwagen war die Wache der sessman ich
hinterm wir fuhren zum Arbeitsplatz die
Leitung hinlegen isolatorum ausmen wo
die Stolpe gesetzt werden soll dann kam
das Kommando hat die Stolp gesz
hochgeklettert und meine Arbeit
verwichtet also ich war denn die jungen
SS Leute haben sich gelangweilt dann
nahm so einen Schnösel sein Gewehr am
Lauf und ging und schwenkte und kam ein
Kopf im Wege des Kolbens umso schlimmer
für den Kopf so das wir fast täglich ein
zwei Leichen ins lag mitragen muss der
der Sadismus von demben so oft berichtet
wird wir sind jetzt sozusagen schon ein
bisschen weiter ich würde gerne Herr
weintraum mit Ihnen noch einmal
zurückgehen
Auschwitz ja als sie nach Auschwitz nach
Birkenau deponiert deportiert worden
sind ähm sie berichten all das was man
kennt diese Reise in diesem in diesem
viehwagon fürchterliche Situation sie
sagen wir standen da da konnte keiner
sitzen da konnte keiner schlafen es
vergingen Tage und Nächte die Notdurft
irgendwo in einem Eimer furchtbare
Gestank von irgendeiner
Decke abgedeckt das war's das war die
linke hintere Ecke genau tote
Menschen irgendwann Menschen die einfach
nicht mehr können und dann kommen sie
irgendwann vollkommen erschöpft und auch
im Kopf völlig erschöpft an Wissen
eigentlich nicht was wirklich auf sie
wartet sie beschreiben das auch und
sagen wir wussten nichts von Auschwitz
wir hatten keine Ahnung davon es wurde
uns niemals gesagt wann und wohin wir
gebracht
werden in dieser Moment es gehen
plötzlich diese Türen dieses Wagons auf
und sie stehen an dieser berüchtigten an
dieser berühmten Rampe in der Mengele
seine Selektion macht was haben Sie
davon in Erinnerung wie war das was
haben sie gehört wie hat's gerochen was
war das für eine
Atmosphäre
zuerst was sie se auffallend
ist ich habe ein gutes Gedächtnis ich
denke in Bildern sehe ich ein Bild kann
ich das Bild beschreiben ich habe keine
Erinnerung von der langen Reise von
Ghetto in nmstadt nach diesem Ort den
ich späterwiesen hab ausch genau es
herrscht eine
todesstille kein Ausdruck der Empörung
der Enttäuschung Proteste
alle sind wir gelähmt man hört überhaupt
kein Wort dann die türre aufgerissen
solche merkwürdige Gestalten wie
Schlafanzügen blau grau weiß
gestreiften Anzügen und das nur das Wort
raus raus raus schnell und schnell nach
vorne ich habe mama zugewint mama wir
sehen uns drin ich habe immer noch nicht
eingesehen wie wir betrogen
wurden den an den Anschlägen auf den
Wänden im August
1944 war diese Perfidie der Nazis in
Sorge um unser Wohl weil es vermeiden
wollen dass wir zwischen die Fronten
kommen da die Front sich nähert mit
wegen unserer Sicherheit das Ghetto
verlegt in Sicherheit in Tiefe des
Dritten Reiches wo wir weiter unsere
nützliche für die Nazis nützliche Arbeit
wie die WM produzieren
können und dann die Reise und dann
angekommen V nach vorne Frauen rechts
Männer links und diesem Trab nach vorne
sehe ich meinen
Augenwinkel
in Stolpen Stacheldraht aber darüber
hinaus weiße Isolatoren und Leitungen
ich war Elektriker im Ghetto ihn war
klar was das bedeutet sofort Strom
führende Leitungen am Zaun wo bin ich
geraten wo hat man uns
gebracht nach vorne gekommen kam der
berühmter Daumen rechts Tod links Leben
auf
Aufschub und wie meine Schwester erzählt
haben als sie nach vorne kam hat
wahrscheinlich Menge runtergebeugt zu
meiner Mutter etwas gefragt meine mter
konnte fließen deutsch und russisch nach
vom Ersten Weltkrieg
her war ja
geboren aber sie hielt krampfhaft fest
an der Hand meiner Tante Eva 10 Jahre
älter als meiner Mutter die sofort den
Finger nach Recht bekommen hat und sie
hat Mama mitgezogen in die Todeszone und
sofort vergast worden an diesem Tag und
ich kam nach vorne ich war so mag ich
warbe aufrecht auch heute halte ich mich
noch ziemlich aufrecht noch nicht
gebeugt nach links also zu
arbeitsfähigen und dann fing an was ich
nenne die Prozedur der
Entmenschlichung alle Attribute eines
Menschen wurde uns abgenommen er ist auf
in ein Gebäude alles
ablegen alles Persönliche abgeben dann
die Dusche dann kam die erste Etappe war
haarschneide lassen eine Reihe Häftlinge
mit haarschneid Maschinen und Haare von
allen behaarten Körperteilen entfernt so
unvorsichtig so und schon geschont weil
hinter uns eine lange Schlange war ist
so manche hautfätze mitgekommen es hat
furchtbar gebrannt bei der nächsten
Etappe wo wieder ein grei heftigge saß
an einem Trog mit einer öligen nach
carbol Phenol übel rieende Flüssigkeit
eine Mop mit dem man heute Fußboden
sauber macht eingetaucht unter Unterleib
unter armkopf gestrichen desinfiziert
das hat Fusch war gebrannt an den
verletzten Hautstellen dann die nächste
Etappe beim Ausgang wieder in eine Reihe
heftige zugeworfen Jacke Hemd Hose
gewiesen ein Haufen von
Holzschuhen und dann wurden wir gebracht
in eine anderes
Gebäude da kam rein ein
wohlgenährte gut aussehende Mann so um
50 und ging auf und ab auf diesen
ziegelaufbau die die beiden ofenstellen
schsteine in diesem Gebäude verbunden
hat und fing an einfach mit den weichen
Ton freundlich mit ein einfach sollte
jemand von uns in den natürlichen
Körperöffnungen
Goldmünzen Schmuck oder andere
Kostbarkeiten versteckt haben wie das
durch rönkenuntersuchung
entdeckt wird war furchtbar bestraft
mein erster Gedanke war furchtbar
bestraft ist das was du bis jetzt
durchgemacht haben nicht Strafe genug da
sind wirklich eine aufgestanden was er
reingeworen ein kleines Gefäß danach
wurden wir aufgeteilt in verschiedenen
Block es war nicht Baracke sondern Block
ich war als Jugendliche im Block Nummer
10 untergebracht und dieser Zeit in
Auschwitz wie ich später erfahren habe
war es eigentlich eine
arbeitskraftreserve hat GRP
Siemens angefordert 200 Arbeitskräfte da
wurden aus dieser Gruppe 200 Menschen
holt und näher zum Arbeitsplatz gebracht
in
arbeitslag ich war eine furchtbaren
pischen Verfassung getrennt von Mutter
schwest sie haben die nicht mehr gesehen
nicht mehr gesehen und vor allem das
Pech in diesem Transport gab es keine
einzige Person die mir von früher
bekannt war ich war völlig mir selbst
lassen waren Gruppen gefangen
worden konnen sich gegenseitig
unterstützen meine drei Schwestern waren
zusammen und wäre meine Mutter bei der
Selektion ein neues
Wort sie hätte eine Chance zu überleben
drei eigenen Töchter quält sie das bis
heute die Frage nach der ich merke das
meine Mutter hätte hätte das war eine
ein Gedanke der mich immer quält eine
Art ich verstehe das
so
da dazu kam der
drückende furchtbar belast
belästigende Geruch Gestank unser Teil
genannt Feld war links waren Gebäude mit
hohen schonsteinen rechts habe ich
Frauen aus die
schstein
qualte Tag und Nacht Nacht ein schwere
schwarze nach verbrannten Fleisch
stinkend der Rauch Warin klar dass da
Menschen verbrannt keine Ahnung ich war
völlig Ahnung sich das nicht erzählt es
war ich hatte mit keinem Mund aufgemacht
ich hat kannte keinen und ich war mich
seh geschlossen ich habe ich
wie unserem Beruf der Medizin gibt es
Ausdruck
Katatonie eine stark man hört und sieht
kann Befehle
ausführen
aber man hat kaum eine höhere
Gehirntätigkeit aktiv ich habe mich ein
Kokon eingeschlossen und das war auch
ein
selbstbewahrungsreflex kann man sagen
Selbsterhaltungstrieb denn das hat mich
verschont das richtig wahrzunehmen was
um mich geschieht son hätte ich durch h
ich hätte es nicht
geschafft
wie oft haben sie sich die Frage
gestellt in der Situation warum warum
machen die das war nein keine
gedankentätigkeit es geht nur noch um
existieren bei Beweis diese
Gedanken
fehlm Abwesenheit von gedenken dass ich
nicht mich nicht erinnern kann
irgendwann mich mir gedankenemacht was
ist mit Mama und mein Schwestern
Geschehen mm ich habe keine
Erinnerung so dass ich eines Tages
zwischen Block 16 18 sah ich eine Gruppe
nackter Männer wie viel es waren es war
ein paar hundert ich habe gewagt mich im
bewunden gebagt was macht dich h nackt
sagten sie wir sind registriert worden
wir wart auf Kleidung um raus zuur
Arbeit aus
das Wort raus wurde ein Signal ohne zu
überlegen völlig unbewusst kann man was
sagen spontan nur links rechts geschaut
keine SS keine schwarze uniforme keine
Kos Funktionäre mit dem KO und in
Schatten des Gebäudes die drei kann
ruhig sagen schmartes Z lumpen und
zerschlissen nach die vielen
Wochen abgeworfen und mich tief
reingedrät in die das sie haben sich
ausgezogen haben ihre Kleider
weggeworfen und haben sich mitten
reingestellt von lauter nackten Menschen
und haben nicht reagiert dann kamen sie
an und S fereinen aufgestellt so Gleid
kleiderkamme und raus zum Arbeits zum
Zug dein
letzte Bild aus ausch wirg genau saß ich
auf der rechten Seite wo das frauenlage
war eine Frau so schräg an den dräen
klebend hat sich an die stromführenden
Leitung geworfen absichtlich ja und dann
sind wir gelandet in großrose wie ich
später erfahren habe nach paar Tagen
fragten sie nach elektrikerern habe ich
mich gemeldet obwohl das ganz was
anderes war als sich im GTO ich habe GTO
Motoren gewwikt Leitungen geschaltet und
die schlimmste Arbeit meinem Leben
Leitungen vom Saal zu Saal zu führen
dicke
Ziegelwände eine Öffnung zu schaffen von
bohmaschinen gab keine Rede aber wir
haben ein so ein genannt schlagrohe
bekommen verzahnt an einem Ende und den
schweren Hamme Millimeter für
millimeterch Bewegung mit Char Chaplin
in modernen
Zeiten ja
Wahnsinn sie haben zwei weitere äh
dieser Lager überstanden überlebt sie
fanden sich dann irgendwann in einem Zug
und und berichten die die unglaubliche
Geschichte der perfide Plan der SS ist
es diesen Zug mit vielen anderen
hunderten Häftlingen im Bodensee zu
versenken ja Fred Trendel ein
Schriftsteller von Don waschingon hat
ein Buch geschrieben die 10 Tage an der
AR und schildert die letzten 10 Tage des
Zweiten Weltkrieges beschreibt genau was
mit uns geschehen ist dass sie von
Offenburg wo ich die das Kommando das
von flossenburg mhm am
25 März
1944 transportiert wurde wie in meinem
Schreiben von Bad arulsen steht nach
Offenburg war waren eingesetzt um die
reminen von den schinen zu räumen manche
sind dabei
aufgegangen in
mein Schreiben in diesem Schreiben steht
auch das wahrscheinlich in flossenburg
aufgenommen bei der Registration und
meine registrationsnummer
82707 das noch heute in den großen Buch
in flossenburg bezeichnet
ist
es ist mich manchmal sehr schwer Worte
dafür zu finden bitte Entschuldigung
verstehe
das ich verstehe das vor allen Dingen
wenn man es gibt ja ein Detail das ich
sie jetzt nicht ansprechen wollte ich
überzähl es einfach mal um mal klar
zumachen wie knapp das auch für sie
alles war dieser gesamte Block 10 von
dem sie gerade gesprochen haben ist
wenig später ins Gas geschickt worden
nur wenige Tage nachdem ihen die Flucht
geglückt ist dies glbwürdiger Augenzeuge
ein Freund der Familie F kuppermann mit
seinem Bruder war ich in der Schule
zusammen mein guter Freund war
Zeuge als der ganze Block Nummer 10 als
untaglich für Arbeit es war immerhin
schon
april also märz
1945 und in die gastkammer gebracht
hatte keine Ahnung davon wie es mir
gelungen ist ausschwi zu entkommen denn
ich wurde nicht kontrolliert ja ist
schon klar weil ich darum habe ich kein
kein ausschnummer
m dieser Zug in dem sie saßen der im
Bodensee versenkt werden sollte der
wurde dann angegriffen von einem
französischen Jagdflieger
die Lokomotive wird angegriffen der Zug
kommt zum halt sie schaffen es zu
entkommen und sind plötzlich draußen
wie muss ich mir das
vorstellau aber wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen dies dieser erste Moment
jetzt bist du draußen und aber immer
noch unter Bewachung so wir wurden
hügelraau Hügel run das war ja so und
wasingon in Schwarzwald genau aber auf
einmal zu unser großen Überraschung
sehen wir uniformstück in den gebisch
und wache weg also müs mit dem Totenkopf
ja mit dem doppelblitz SS Zeichen
entnarzifizierung würde ich sagen ja auf
die Schnelle und wir habens auch die
bische geschlagen so schwach ich war
aber doch gelenklich wir hörten Schüsse
da haben sie mir geholfen am Baum
hochzuklettern ich konnte ins Tal
runterschauen und sah dass
eine Lokomotive vom links also vom Osten
angekommen ist Leute noch rangetrieben
in den Zug der Zug ist nach links
abgefahren nach dem Osten und wir haben
bisschen abgewartet gegen Morgengrauen
in ent gegensetzte Richtung und da stand
war auch einmal vor der nauerschingen
aber unterwegs waren auf einmal kam in
der Schneise auf far den drei Soldaten
die haben uminander den Kreis gemacht
die hatten Angst vor uns wie vor ihnen
waren acht heftlinge ungefähr ich war
der jüngste und dann kam wir an ein
schneisean da kam auf einmal hinter der
Kurve ein Lastwagen da drauf sahen wir
ein schwarzes Gesicht am maschinengeweh
mit dem Turban hat Angst bekommen WUs
nicht was das ist in den Wald gesprungen
da hörten wir ein Schuss so kamen wir
raus Hände hoch da kam s gegen
hochgewachsene Soldaten ganz andere
Uniform mit eine Pistole an uns
gerichtet da zeigt
wir KL Konzentrationslager mit einem
Kalkfarbe auf der Jacke aufgeschmiert
und zeigt auf den Kopf ein Streifen der
haarstein der Maschine rausgeschnitten
um uns zu kennzeichnen als Häftlinge als
er näher kam ich sehe ihn vor
mir schiebt die Pistole hoch fängt mit
der linken Hand auf streckt die Hand auf
sag kom und zeig mit dem Daumen diese
Richtung und da kamen wir an stad
chingen die Stadt war leer aber entgegen
und kam schon Fremdarbeiter mit
vollgepackten Handwerken auf dem Weg
nach Hause wahrscheinlich und wir gingen
rein in Haus ich habe mir rausgucht pa
Unterhosen Hose ein Hemd in eine Jacke
Paar Schuhe das hat mir gereicht und da
gingen weit am Gasthof zur Sonne sage
ich meineen Freunden vielleicht gehen
wir da rein
hab uns da eingerichtet ich habe ein
etwas von meinem künftigen Beruf in der
deutschen Sprache ist das Wort Beruf
wenn man das Wort ung daran hängt wird
es zu
Berufung und das Warin der Beruf als
Frauen als Geburtshelfer späte ganz
bewusst gewählt war die Berufung und
habe ich sie gewarnt wenn wir essen
finden bitte unser Magen ist nicht dran
gewöhnt vorsichtig ich habe Mehl
gefunden aufgekocht bisschen Salz und
eine panche Wahnsinn und damit und dann
abends ich konnte nicht einschlafen in
den weichen Bett hatte gefühlt dass ich
falle falle falle erst auf dem buuboden
konnte ich einschlafen